this video was made possible by nordvpn
go to nordvpn.com forward slash vpn and
get a two-year plan at a super discount
more on that in a moment
[Music]
the war in ukraine has turned the global
political agenda upside down suddenly
the eyes of the whole world have shifted
back to europe russia and ukraine and
oil and gas seem to be the hot topics
however have you ever heard the
expression don't let the urgent things
prevent you from taking care of the
important things well that is exactly
what the united states and particularly
joe biden's administration is doing you
see visual politic fans the white house
is very clear that in the long term asia
remains the number one priority
[Music]
so far from looking the other way what
they want in washington is precisely to
step on the accelerator they hope to
take advantage of the unease the fear
generated by the russian invasion and
the fact that now suddenly the united
states has once again become the ally of
choice the friend everyone wants to have
and so at the end of may 2022 in the
midst of the war in ukraine and while
the pentagon continued to send more and
more weapons to the european front u.s
president joe biden made an important
visit to south korea and japan two close
allies of the united states that lately
have been frantically trying to
strengthen their ties with the u.s power
at all levels by the way this visit was
celebrated with fireworks and a joint
airshow by the usual annoying neighbours
russian and chinese jets patrol east
asia skies as biden visits hours after
biden leaves asia north korea launches a
suspected icbm and two other missiles
the fact is that as we have already
mentioned here and there the united
states has been promoting a significant
network of alliances throughout the asia
pacific region for years and if in
recent years the north american policy
has been practically limited to closer
military ties now the biden
administration wants to do the same in
the political and economic fields
[Music]
as vice president biden was part of the
administration that led the tpp the
trans-pacific trade agreement that was
later abandoned by donald trump and one
of the great mistakes of u.s foreign
policy the white house is now studying
how to resume that line of work all with
a three-fold goal three objectives that
the united states considered
indispensable in order to remain the
number one power in the asia-pacific
region the first of these which we have
already discussed at length in past
videos involves curbing the expansion of
chinese influence and demonstrating that
the united states is still an essential
player even if this means taking a much
tougher more active and belligerent line
on taiwan
biden vows to defend taiwan in apparent
u.s policy shift and here is one thing
to keep in mind as much as the white
house and the secretary of state tend to
qualify the president's words after the
fact to make it clear the united states
has not changed his position on its
policy of strategic ambiguity which
basically involves not making it clear
when and how taiwan would be defended it
doesn't matter biden's repeated
assertion that the u.s would intervene
actively and militarily to defend taiwan
is no accident but a statement of intent
the second major objective is to try to
stimulate a three-way relationship with
two of its closest allies said korea and
japan in other words washington wants
these two countries to improve their
relations and put their old diplomatic
conflicts behind them once and for all
in order to build a strong democratic
front in the region we are after all
talking about two of the wealthiest and
most technology-like advanced countries
in the world two countries that combined
have a gdp of seven trillion dollars and
a military budget that could reach 150
billion dollars per year
in other words we would be talking about
one of the strongest jews in the world
finally the third point washington's
major third objective is to promote a
network of alliances to achieve greater
military political and economic
integration especially economic with the
countries of the region well during his
latest trip biden gave us many clues
about what uncle sam's new foreign
policy would look like these visual
policy viewers are the plans that the
biden administration has for keeping
china no more than a minor player but
before we continue are you aware of how
necessary it is nowadays to have a vpn
summer is just around the corner and i'm
sure many of you are thinking about
taking a vacation right well don't
forget to pack nordvpn in your suitcase
in fact using nordvpn when you're
planning your trip can help you source
cheaper flights rental cars and hotel
bookings and not only that are you going
to another country but want to continue
watching your favorite series with
nordvpn servers you'll be sure to be
able to access your country's content
whilst traveling anywhere in the world
but is browsing speed affected by
nordvpn well not only is it fast but
according to an independent study by av
test nord is the fastest vpn on the
planet what's more you can use it on all
types of devices android windows max
linux and with the same account you can
include up to six different devices
don't wait any longer make the most of
your internet experience and take
advantage of a special offer for the
visualpolitik community go to
nordvpn.com forward slash vpn and get a
two-year plan for the price of one soda
a month and if you change your mind
after trying it don't worry nordvpn has
a 30-day money-back guarantee we'll
leave you a link in the description and
now let's get cracking
a premier summit
it may be surprising but if there is one
thing that evidence tells us is that
international relations are very very
much influenced by the personal
relationships between the various
political leaders
in international relations all politics
is personal because it's all ultimately
based on trust and trust only flows from
personal not friendly candid
relationships with your counterpart so
you don't have to wonder about
intentions vice president joe biden in
south korea in 2013. and guess what the
us leader's visit to south korea was
such a success that biden and the new
south korean president seem to have hit
it off very well but obviously this is
not a soap opera so here the bromance is
a bit inconsequential to us and at
visualpolitik we are here mainly
concerned with the facts well on the
political front in october of 2021 the
united states announced the creation of
a new asia-pacific cooperation framework
the so-called indo-pacific economic
framework the new ipef and yes south
korea has been invited to be one of its
founding members and of course yoon has
accepted now what is this framework and
why on earth would washington want to
create a new international forum if the
united states could simply rejoin the
cptp which is now led mainly by japan
and has become the trending club
well unlike the cptpp the ipef is not
free trade agreement that seeks to
eliminate tariffs and trade barriers for
the time being its main intention is to
promote the economic integration of the
14 founding countries that is for
example to promote close regulatory
exchange experiences and promote
cooperation agreements in areas such as
technology the digital economy clean
energy and the fight against corruption
and above all more than anything else
what the forum seeks is to strengthen
supply chains between member countries
so they do not have to depend so much on
china
[Music]
let's not kid ourselves we are talking
about a forum whose mission does not yet
seem very clear but it seems that
washington aspires for this forum to be
one of the central axes of u.s foreign
policy and to function as a
counterweight to any integration
movement led by china as is the case of
the regional comprehensive economic
partnership the rcep
[Music]
there is even speculation that in the
medium term the us government's idea is
that this new framework will eventually
give rise to a new much broader free
trade and economic cooperation agreement
an agreement that would allow for
instance the promotion of initiatives on
strategic issues such as microchips the
latch of which is greatly affecting the
automotive technological and military
industries around the world including of
course the u.s industry in fact just
after biden's visit to south korea and
after south korea agreed to join ipef
two important announcements were made
check this out
south korea's sk announces
billion investment for chips batteries
bio through 2026
samsung to invest 355 billion dollars to
cement lead in chip biosectors to give
you an idea these two investments
combined represent the equivalent of the
entire gdp of countries such as norway
or israel in other words overnight this
industry has become south korea's
national priority coincidence hardly but
let's not stop there
in addition to the ipef biden and yoon
also reached important military
agreements such as increasing the u.s
deterrent forces deployed in the area to
deal with north korean provocations as
well as the frequency and quantity with
which strategic weapons would be
deployed if pyongyang steps out of lane
joint military exercises will also be
resumed as regularly as they were
conducted before former president moon
canceled many maneuvers to avoid
angering kim yong-un that's not all
there is also speculation that south
korea could unilaterally put an end to
the military restrictions that xi
jinping and moon jae-in agreed in order
to stop the retaliation with which
beijing punished south korea after the
united states deployed the third missile
sealed in south korea we are talking
about what is known as the three-nose
agreement
under this agreement south korea pledged
first that there would be no more
anti-missile systems in the country
secondly that seoul would not join any
u.s led regional anti-missile system and
thirdly that it would not be part of any
military alliance involving south korea
japan and the united states at the same
time all in exchange for china putting
an end to the economic reprisals that
for example caused hyundai sales in
china to plummet by 64 percent forced
the lotte group to liquidate all its
operations in china and halted the
transit of chinese tourists to seoul
well be that as it may the agreement now
seems to be put however it remains to be
seen how seoul will manage the aftermath
in any case the relationship with seoul
is far from the only card biden hopes to
play he is doing exactly the same with
japan the land of the rising sun has not
only committed to expanding its military
budget strengthening its political role
in the region and even trying to improve
its relationship with seoul is also and
above all increasing its engagement with
the united states and the latter's
closest allies for example japan has
signed significant military agreements
with australia and the united kingdom in
this way the united states is creating a
coalition capable of restraining china
on its own of course in this area
bilateral relations are not the only ace
washington has up its sleeve
[Music]
road to deterrence
[Music]
in addition to boosting bilateral
relations the biden administration's
other major priority is to consolidate
half-built military alliances i'm
talking particularly about the quad
we're not going to give you many details
about it because we specifically
dedicated a video to it here on
visualpolitik in the past but it is true
that following the russian invasion of
ukraine the united states now wants to
step on the accelerator to finish
fleshing out an alliance formed by the
united states japan india and australia
an alliance that met in tokyo just after
biden's trip to south korea and has
brought with it some new developments
for example quad levers have now agreed
to launch a major maritime initiative
the indo-pacific partnership for
maritime domain awareness or ipmda
there's a lot of acronyms in this
quad leaders roll out major initiative
to improve monitoring maritime
activities across indo-pacific and what
exactly is this for
the idea is that the new partnership
will allow increased real-time
monitoring of the indo-pacific seas by
member countries and we are not only
talking about a military function this
initiative will also make it possible to
control the navigation of the so-called
dark ships vessels that sail with their
detection systems disconnected and are
often linked to illegal fishing
smuggling or trade with countries
sanctioned by the international
community as is the case with north
korea for example
[Music]
and it goes even further the four
nations of the quad have also agreed the
creation of the quad cyber security
partnership
quad calls for collective approach to
enhance cyber security the quad
countries called for a collective
approach to enhance cyber security and
said they will coordinate capacity
building programs in the indo-pacific
region under the quad cybersecurity
partnership of course it's not all good
news india has refused to strongly
condemn russia's invasion of ukraine
because it fears vladimir putin's
country will cancel deliveries of
military equipment
[Music]
meanwhile and this is something we will
talk about in a future video in
australia the labour party has come to
power and there is a fear that the new
government in canberra wants to cool its
growing hostility to china in order to
redirect trade relations and get beijing
to cancel the tariffs with witches as
hoped to punish the australian economy
be that as it may if one thing is clear
is that in recent years there has been a
180 degree turnaround the u.s position
in the asia pacific becoming the
strongest it has been in a very long
time with south korea japan australia
and the alliances that are being forged
such as the quad and the indo-pacific
economic framework the biden
administration hopes to consolidate the
united states position as a major power
in the asia pacific while until
relatively recently everything pointed
to china taking the upper hand the shift
in u.s political strategy has changed
everything both in the european and
pacific theater of course the game is
not yet over and the question is will
biden's plans come to fruition will the
u.s strategy succeed and will washington
succeed in weakening the power and
influence of russia and china at the
same time leave us your comments below
if you found this video interesting and
don't forget to like and subscribe to
all of us here at visualpolitik all the
best and i'll see you next time
[Music]